another great story today in boston the
marathon is being held again for the
first time in nearly two and a half
years and nancy chan is already at the
finish line nancy good morning to you
must be nice to start the morning at the
finish line
yeah i didn't run all 26.2 miles to get
here good morning to you tony yeah this
is the first time the boston marathon
has been held in the fall delayed from
its usual date in april because of the
pandemic there will also be fewer people
participating this year because of the
pandemic with the field size cut by 36
percent among those participating though
a dynamic duo hoping to make history
that went pretty smooth
all right talk to me
which way
when you ask beth craig what pushes her
forward it's all in the name team babsie
for her mom barbara singleton so i
always tell everybody she's sort of the
heart i'm just the legs in the back and
now with three marathons under their
belt the mother-daughter duo is tackling
boston's iconic race it's believed craig
would be the first daughter to push her
mom across the finish line she inspires
me to do a lot of things i wouldn't
normally do that's true but you don't
say no so that's the problem
their adventures started seven years ago
after craig spotted dick and rick hoyt
the father and son famous for completing
32 boston marathons and inspiring people
with disabilities around the world
craig soon started pushing her mother
who has multiple sclerosis with dick
hoyt cheering them on dick and wreck we
feel like changed the direction of our
relationship and allowed us to
just be devoted to each other as mother
and daughter again
singleton was diagnosed with early onset
ms when craig was 15. the two growing
apart as their dynamic changed before
running brought them back together
what does your mom mean to you she's my
hero right she's
she's doing so much
and
when i say this this
gorgeous lady smiles every day i don't
know how she does it
and the two are raising money for the
hoyt foundation they will also be
running in honor of dick hoyt who passed
away in march at the age of 80 gail
boy nancy thank you so much go go miss
craig and her mom i mean i think they're
each other's heroes actually
where they look at one another yeah
there's nothing like that
mother-daughter i was gonna say that too
i was thinking that exact same thing
nate